whatever you want to say about me
i am not a liberal and i find that most
of my friends on the right are not
liberals
but we're told that to be a conservative
today is to be a liberal that the
conservatives are the real liberals and
the liberals have become leftists and
the leftists are like the socialists and
the radicals and the marxists but not
the classical liberals except for some
and it's very
very confusing but i know
that i'm not a liberal i know it down in
my gut
i know that i am a conservative but what
does it mean to be a conservative well
my friend joram pezoni will help us to
discover that uh because he's got a
wonderful new book out conservatism a
rediscovery joram thank you for coming
on the show
you're very welcome and you should know
that there was not one minute during my
entire life where i thought i was a
liberal i am i'm envious of you that you
knew that because
especially these days and especially in
this country
i fear that the liberals have gone
completely radical and half the
conservatives are liberals and we can't
even articulate what it means to be a
conservative is to be a conservative to
be a great defender of liberty
whatever that means is to be a
conservative to be
like those
17th and 18th century people who call
themselves liberals or is to be a
conservative something different
there is there's a third
there is a third option a conservative
is somebody who
uh sees
uh who sees
religious and political tradition
as the key to
um
maintaining a nation through time and
building up its strength all right so
the the the uh you can tell you're
talking to a conservative because
they're always trying to focus on
is
is is my nation or is a certain nation
is it
uh becoming cohesive is it becoming
stronger is it becoming something that's
more capable of
propagating through time handing on its
traditions to its children
or is it becoming less so and that's a
very very different way of thinking
about politics than uh than liberals
liberals you know
we all know lots of liberals liberalism
basically
begins with
the idea that
human beings are by nature free and
equal
and uh and then goes on to say well you
know what's the purpose of government it
must be to defend the freedom and
equality that it belongs to individuals
by by nature i mean
we've all heard a million variations of
that and the question is what's the
relationship between somebody who
who think who begins with the individual
and says the individual has all of these
liberties by nature and and the point of
politics is to protect them and a
conservative who says
hold hold on a second
if society doesn't political society
doesn't think about anything other than
the freedom and equality of individuals
then what's going to happen to trying to
actually propagate this thing over
generations and centuries the
conservative immediately moves to
thinking
you know
aren't there some kinds of restraints
that we need
aren't there some kinds of things that
we need to be handing down
things we need to do in order to be able
to transmit um good and important and
true things to future generations and
the moment you ask that you're in a
different you're in a different
conversation this is a totally different
way of viewing things because
the classical liberal
and the modern liberal they're both
beginning their look at politics from
the lens of rights what are my natural
rights what are my positive rights what
are all the rights that i'm entitled to
what you're saying is the conservative
looks at politics and says hey
what are my circumstances what's my
family what are my natural loyalties and
relationships what are my obligations
that i have i'm i'm born into this world
not as a free-floating atom that has all
sorts of abstract rights i'm born into
this world as a little baby to a mommy
and a daddy and maybe i've got some
siblings and maybe i'm in a church and
i've got some responsibilities there and
i've got some responsibilities to my
nation it's
it's as though we're we're not even
having the same conversation that the
liberals are yeah
i i think it's a very different
conversation
but at this point i mean if we take a
look at america britain various other
countries uh which have been
um
operating under the assumption let's say
at least since world war ii there's been
this assumption
that that these are liberal democracies
that was you know before world war ii
nobody used that expression pretty much
but but the idea that that um that
liberalism it's it's the the it is the
public kind of the public religion or
the public philosophy of the united
states and of other european countries
and we've been
these countries have been in this
framework
now for i don't know about 60 years
except that in 2020 it basically
collapsed i mean i don't know if people
have
quite
grasped this yet but
there was the 60 years of we can call
you know the hegemony of liberal ideas
which is just fancy talk for saying
you know basically everybody who was
anybody was a liberal and anybody else
was on you know was on the sidelines and
even and even the conservatives were
liberals even most of the conservatives
were liberal
and
that sort of monopoly that that
basically you had to be one kind of
liberal or another in in order to be
legitimate in society
that's collapsed that that's that's
broken in 2020 most of the liberal
institutions
in
america and the uk and a lot of other
places
capitulated in front of this wave of
woke neo-marxism
which you know it's it's related to
liberalism in some ways but it really is
a different worldview and and you can
you can see that it's a different
worldview you can see that something big
has changed
liberals no longer have the monopoly and
uh under these circumstances uh where
we're where
liberalism is
is quickly it it really is quickly
declining
and i i would think that if if you were
a liberal you'd want to know you know
what did we do wrong
you know you'd want to say uh
we thought that the whole world would
just become more and more reasonable
that everybody would adopt liberalism
that all countries would adopt
liberalism and people really believed
that you know just a little while ago
and now it's obviously false and so
uh the the
the conservative question
what would you need to do in order to be
able to propagate anything
through the generations to preserve
anything we know we've seen that
liberalism doesn't have what it takes to
do so what would it have to be like we
joke now we say that the conservatives
during the 60 years of hegemonic
liberalism the conservatives didn't even
conserve the women's bathroom we didn't
conserve anything we didn't conserve
marriage we didn't conserve
biological sex we didn't conserve
admiration for our country we now
regularly protest the american flag we
might not be preserving the supreme
court and other institutions of
government we we had eight months of
widespread writing that was cheered on
by the political class we didn't
conserve
anything and you know
i i think that
under a certain age almost everybody's
anybody's right of center
is saying that
we need to ask the question what would
you have to do in order to be able to
conserve something first of all just
because it's this obvious question you
can't get away with i mean
are there societies that are capable of
conserving anything and if so what would
you have to do to be like so there's
that
and there's an additional question which
which i i don't think we can avoid which
is that an awful lot of young people i'm
sure i'm sure you can encounter this all
the time an awful lot of young people
who see that liberalism has collapsed
and think that the
the the the neo-marxist thing is
completely insane
a lot of those young people are
themselves
turning to you know all sorts of
characters on the sort of further right
who are advocating advocating you know
one kind or another of
of of uh dictatorship and fascism and i
mean a lot of them explicitly saying
look uh christianity judaism the bible
uh you know the the anglo-american
tradition the american constitution a
lot of them are saying look all of these
things they're defeated they're gone we
saw that they can't hold their own
you know i i don't i don't think i don't
think that's true
but you know if we better have that
argument right now right yes it it's
sometimes called
horseshoe theory i think that when you
get far enough right it's difficult to
distinguish between the people on the
far right from the far left i mean i've
seen this when we're you're talking
about very very extreme people on the
right they'll often be in favor of
abortion or some kind of eugenics policy
just like the people on the far left and
the people in the kind of normal right
you know or the
they that's where you find pro-life that
you'll fi i find that people on the very
very far right are very anti-christian
they'll and explicitly so they'll be
sort of militant atheists or pagans or
something like that i mean they're so so
what you're saying is okay liberalism's
collapsed we need some alternative but
you don't you don't want people to
become a bunch of you know baby-killing
pagans who want to destroy western
civilization yeah i think i i think if
if if we just sort of summarize like
where the discussion is pretty much the
discussion is uh fewer and fewer people
are are
consciously real liberal still you know
still holding on for dear life
large numbers of people moving far left
smaller numbers of people moving and
especially among younger people moving
to you know into this to the far right
and then there's this big vacuum there's
this big space
which um you know you and i and and
various of our colleagues have been
trying to
uh argue that there is there is such a
thing as national conservatism as a
nationalist conservatism which is
about preserving
the religious and political traditions
of the nation
that's a hard case to make now because
the the traditions are so weak but
if there's going to be an alternative
it's going to be in that space and it's
going to be on that subject right so
for young people who have been just
completely
either not educated or male educated
they've been taught things that aren't
true
how are they supposed to answer their
professors when the professors or their
teachers or when their professors say
look the only thing that even resembles
conservatism in america is conserving
liberalism
you hear this a lot the the founding
fathers they were all liberals john
locke practically wrote the constitution
uh and the declaration of independence
you know this is uh this is all
liberalism so
even if you wanted to conserve something
in america that was not liberalism you
could not do it
yeah this is this is a
an important famous argument which won
the day
um
roughly in the 1940s 1950s meaning the
people who are saying it they're
claiming this was true since the day
that america was founded we've always
been liberals but the question is is
historically
when did peop people actually believe
that when did people think that america
has always been liberal and and by the
way it's it's kind of funny that that
americans say that they've always been
liberal you know since the revolution
and french say that they've always been
liberal since the french revolution and
the english say that they've always been
liberal since since the the glorious
revolution and the germans just say that
they've always been liberal and it no
every every every major nation has this
same brainwash yeah and they were all
born at the same time they're all
post-world war ii people come out of the
trauma of uh of of world war ii
and they say we've
uh the two world wars and they say
we've got to do something completely
different radically different we have to
make sure this never happens again and
that's when the big push
to uh to turn
uh to turn away from
um
different traditions of uh
of um uh
catholic democracy
protestant republicanism the pre-world
war theories of of you know of what
european europe and america were
it's after world war ii
that that stuff just gets erased
and you you find books by famous
professors for the first time in in the
19
you know
late 40s 1950s arguing
this that the united states was born
liberal that that it never had any
conservatives and that argument won the
day for a while and it's completely
false i mean other than that it's fine
it's a perfectly good idea but it isn't
it isn't very very effective but it's
it's not historically no it's it it's
it's extremely effective there was a
moment where
uh american professors and intellectuals
said george washington is not going to
be the father of our country thomas
jefferson is and
thomas jefferson really was the kind of
uh of liberals that we're talking about
that did exist at the american founding
what they skip is that the american
constitution was written by the other
party
and and that that theory depend
believing that theory depends on
believing
that that there weren't two parties at
the american founding a liberal party
and a conservative party uh the the the
the national conservative party at the
american founding was called the
federalists
and uh the the the main players
george washington
uh john jay
alexander hamilton john adams and a guy
named governor morris
he's got this this great name you'd
think people would would talk about him
nobody ever talks about him he's the guy
who actually drafted the american
constitution of 1787 like you know kind
of an important guy to know what he
actually thought so
these these
uh five and their party uh the way that
they looked at the american founding was
um uh there was the american revolution
in 17th 1776
and uh and then there were 13
independent countries and we tried to
fight a war against britain uh being 13
independent countries overthrowing the
traditions and the the the the british
traditions that we had inherited
and it didn't work
at almost no point during the war was
washington able to raise the troops he
needed
to pay the troops that he needed for
what they were doing he rarely had the
money that he needed to actually be able
to move the troop
yorktown you know the glorious i don't
mean to make fun of this but it's
important to know yorktown the glorious
victory you know when the the french
swoop in and the the american troops
come down you know
from the north and and that's it we
you know the americans won we won so but
but those troops were moved by private
donations
like individuals wrote checks the
continental congress couldn't even fund
the movement of the troops for the
battle couldn't right to the battle to
win the war
the
george washington and his officers
knew
from years of experience that america
came this close to having to to being
completely wiped out in this war and the
reason was because
the view that says look all you need
really is liberty
you know like all we need is freedom
like we'll we'll all be free it's like
the beatles all you need is love no what
does that mean right it's all it's just
like all you need is freedom and and all
you need is freedom how does that work
well people are going to volunteer
they're going to see that it's not in
their interests you know to have the
british rule them and so they're going
to go to war and people are going to you
know it's all
everybody's going to volunteer to do
everything yeah and
washington says this is this is this is
this is not reality this is this is
insanity right and so the the
conservatives who founded america the
national nationalist conservatives what
they did this is this was washington was
was saying this throughout very early in
the war
that we're going to need a government
that is a lot like the british
government it has to be a strong central
government with a very powerful
executive and and uh
balanced by uh you know bicameral
legislature with all sorts of inherited
british traditions like you know the
jury trial and the legislature being
responsible for taxation and the
legislature making the laws and and the
executive veto i mean you can just go on
and on
what washington and his
comrades
his fellows
most of the people at the the the con
the the convention that wrote the
constitution the majority had been
officers with washington in his army
and what these guys said was
there's no hope for us if we don't have
a restoration of something that looks a
lot like the british constitution like
the traditional english constitution
those were conservatives those those
conservatives are the people who founded
america as a nation
they brought english common law into
um the the federal government in the
united states and established the the
british tradition officially is the
legal tradition of the united states
and and then these guys after world war
ii say well no um there were no
conservatives they weren't conserving
anything it all would like you know came
out of the it was it was
it was thomas jefferson made it all up
out of the brilliance of his head don't
you know don't you know don't you see
it's amazing even the way it's taught
now we're told there were not political
parties at the founding of the country
that only developed later on as we
approached the election of 1800 and uh
you know it wasn't that the federalists
the conservatives that they really are
responsible for the constitution it was
just kind of everybody got together and
there were no sides and was all it was
all kind of kumbaya frankly even usually
taught that conservatism is a younger
political
vision than liberalism because
conservatism is just a reaction to
liberalism and so it doesn't have much
of a history and it's kind of incoherent
and i think it was lionel trilling who
said that conservatism is not a coherent
uh worldview it's rather a series of
irritable mental gestures
all of you're saying all of that's
false i i'm saying all that's propaganda
it's it's not just false it's it it's
something that was um designed
uh by
uh intellectuals who actually
um
uh saw an opportunity after world war ii
to to just say we can we can get to
utopia and we can we can just eliminate
all of the
uh uh the evil in the world by
adopting
enlightenment liberalism as an official
like an official state religion
basically and
that that was
uh in the united states that that was
that began being implemented in the
1940s
um with uh
the late 1940s you already see the first
supreme court decisions after world war
ii saying um that separation of church
and state you know has been america's
constitution
you know
since its founding but they only
discovered that in 1947.
i mean it's a little bit strange
it's especially strange because
for instance uh
one of the reasons for uh not
establishing a church at the national
level at the constitution
is that there were established churches
at the state level it wasn't to protect
people from the government have any
having any role with religion right it
was that you already had state
establishments so
in 1948
uh the american supreme court in in in
mcculloch
rules unconstitutional the following set
up in chicago schools chicago public
schools
voluntary
student participation in religious
instruction the students get to choose
whether they want to learn from a
catholic a protestant or a jew during
school hours about religion okay that's
1948 like half the states in the united
states had something like that system
and that's what they that's what the
supreme court ruled unconstitutional is
this you know this uh cooperative
teaching of of god in scripture to to
children in the schools
by the 1960s the supreme court rules
prayer
unconstitutional rules bible instruction
if it has anything to do with with
religion unconstitutional and the united
states is uh shifts from being a
you know what what franklin roosevelt
called a god-fearing democracy
it shifts from god fearing democracy to
liberal democracy
and that's the 60th year experiment that
that
we tried and it failed now now we better
do something else
it's it was such effective propaganda
that even i had believed that story for
for
most of my conscious political life most
conservatives i know have believed that
for
most of my political life and it so
you've seen it crumble around you you've
seen this it really only you notice huh
maybe something's off here when when you
point out
i was really about the 50s and 60s that
all of a sudden you see
before that for goodness sakes there
were blasphemy laws in the country at
various points no one thought that was
and then there were sabbath laws
there are all sorts of things that are
unimaginable right and and for and and
now we are told that if you believe that
marriage is between a man and a woman if
you believe that that is a true
statement that you are so reactionary
you are so out of keeping with the
american tradition where that was
universally acknowledged to be the case
until about five minutes ago is so as to
be you should be cast into the outer
darkness where there's wailing and
gnashing of teeth
so you you mentioned this this another
piece of bizarre propaganda that that uh
edmond burke founded conservatism if you
just think about it for i think for a
moment i mean it's such a strange thing
to say he
he founded the tradition that he's
conserving
he was he became the great conservative
by arguing for conservatism but he
invented the whole thing and and so he
was actually a revolutionary
doesn't make a lot of sense so i i i
begin my my new book with a little bit
of history and uh and i think i think a
lot of readers are going to be
um astonished to discover
that if you go back in the english
common law tradition
to the 1400s you could probably go
earlier but in the 1400s there's a a
great anglo-conservative thinker named
john fordescu
who wrote a book called in praise of the
laws of england it's very easy to read
it's available in a in in a uh in in a a
new cambridge edition where where they
they fix the spelling so it's just a
breeze and it's short
and there it is it's the 1470s and this
english political theorist is explaining
um
the separation of powers he's saying
why is why is the english constitution
the greatest constitution in the world
why is it better than the french or the
german or other constitutions and he's
explaining well there's the separation
of powers
between the king and parliament and the
the uh the system of checks and balances
and he talks about the fact that our
king is under law and uh that there's
rule of law and and uh
which is protected by the jury trial and
explains the difference between the
english jury trial and the the system in
france where they torture people in
order to find out whether they did
things or not and he says that's like
the road to hell not to justice but but
he's
he he he he he talks about property he
talks about how property is is is this
fundamental english right why because
property is the key not just to
prosperity for everyone but also to
freedom and he talks about how in
england the king has no right to enter
the home of the lowliest peasant and to
take anything that belongs to him or
even to enter without his permission now
this is being written in the 1470s and
it and it it it
it's a tradition that is if you're an
american
it's your tradition it's where you it it
it's where this all came from and when
burke 300 years later after fortescue
when when burke is defending this
tradition he doesn't think he's
inventing conservatism he's explicitly
saying that all of these great thinkers
for centuries and centuries who who
created the english common law tradition
and and and the the system that brings
um
individual liberty but also uh uh um
religion and national independence and
all these things that we consider
conservative or at least you know
conservatives consider them conservative
burke is finding in a tradition that's
many centuries old
and um look if you're conservative
if you're thinking maybe you want to be
conservative and even if you're one of
these people who's saying conservative
conservatism never conserves anything
then
you stop reading liberals yeah stop
reading the propaganda i mean you drink
the kool-aid it it it does things to
your brain
that's right that's you ought to you
don't need to discover something anew
you can actually rediscover something
that is
700 years old now almost you can do that
in conservatism or rediscovery by joram
hazoni your thank you so much for coming
on and i look forward as we now get past
all of this liberal propaganda as we try
to reassert some confident understanding
of what it means to be a conservative i
look forward to really elevating the way
in which we will be owning the libs into
the future and hopefully rebuilding
something of our civilization thank you
for coming out sounds fantastic thank
you
[Music]
[Music]